[Musique]
le sang total que les donneurs donne en
fait est divisé en plusieurs parties ce
qui fait qu'un donneur peut aider
plusieurs patients à la fois c'est la
magie de la transfusion des globules
rouges du plasma ou des plaquettes qui
sont les trois parties issues du sang
total
le
l'établissement français du sang prend
souvent la route n'hésite pas à sortir
de ses locaux pour aller à la rencontre
des donneurs bénévoles
aujourd'hui direction l'île bouchard
nous voici dans la salle municipale
pendant cinq heures les dons vont se
succéder une mécanique bien rodée pour
mettre le donneur en confiance carole
leclerc de la responsable adjointe des
prélèvements de produits sanguins
[Musique]
ici
une heure au total en sachant qu'il ya
des temps différents puisque vous allez
être reçus y avoir un accueil
administratif et ensuite effectivement
la partie de préparation d'un
questionnaire qui va être ensuite revu
avec le médecin qui va vous poser
effectivement des questions pour savoir
si vous pouvez donner en sachant que
parmi ces questions on va regarder
l'intérêt du donneur en aucun cas on
peut ne prélever une poche si
effectivement c'est préjudiciable à sa
santé et puis on va regarder aussi la
filière receveur s'assurer qu'en donnant
n'y a pas de risque pour leur semaine
c'est donc là que commence ce parcours
de la poche de sang de la veine du
donneur à celle du receveur
cette poche sera soumise à de multiples
examens et des tests donnent un receveur
ne se croiseront jamais mais leurs
données sanguines seront mises en
parallèle pour être au plus proche de
leur compatibilité
[Musique]
direction nantes au laboratoire de
l'établissement français du sang proche
du chu de l'hôtel dieu
c'est ici qu'arrivent les prélèvements
transporté durant la nuit dans une
chambre réfrigérée
ils seront préparés en suivant un
processus très précis la poche et
filtrée pour enlever les globules blancs
puis centrifugé pour séparer les
composants emmanuel rivery et le
responsable du service préparation des
produits sanguins
on a 24 heures pour traiter nos produits
des dons issus des collectes avoir
différentes faces pour valoriser ce dont
on va voir la phase d'enregistrement du
produit qui va nous permettre de faire
une traçabilité totale entre le donneur
et le receveur
on va avoir une phase qui va être de
pliage et de centrifugation qui va
permettre de se séparer de façon
technique le plasma laisser gérer les
plaqués dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
une phase de séparation technique qui
cette fois ci va permet d'avoir
différentes poches de sang la poches de
plasma dédié au plasma la poche dédié
aux plaquettes et la poste dédié aux
globules rouges
ensuite tous ces produits là seront des
filtres et à travers un filtre ce qui va
permettre d'éliminer tous les globules
blancs qui sont vecteurs de virus ce qui
va rendre plus plus sécuritaire le
produit les produits seront conservées à
des températures différentes jusqu'à 30
degrés pour les plaquettes ce sens est
utilisé à 30% pour l'urgence et 70% pour
des interventions chirurgicales
programmées ou encore des traitements
cancérologie par exemple mais aussi pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique en
thérapeutique direct pour les globules
rouges le plasma et les plaquettes et la
thérapeutique indirects ce sont les
médicaments dérivés du sang c'est à dire
qu'à partir du plasma
on va extraire différentes protéines
différents immunoglobulines qui vont
permettre de faire des médicaments
dérivés du sang pour une thérapeutique
indirects à nantes comme dans tous les
centres de l'établissement français du
sang
c'est le temps qui conditionnent tout
on a un enjeu majeur c'est de valoriser
le produit jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire à
limiter les pertes lors du process mais
également en termes de péremption doit
pas périmé en tout cas le moins possible
pour ce faire on va organiser le
notre production dans ce cadre là il
faut savoir laisser grc 42 jours de
péremption
mais plasma c'est environ un an alors
que les plaquettes ces cinq à sept jours
donc ses nerfs de la guerre ses nerfs de
notre guerre de tous les jours et on se
doit et c'est ce que l'équipe fait ici
de mettre en place le système pour que
ces plaquettes soient disponibles le
soir même du prélèvement on va dire ce
qui permet d'avoir des produits très
frais pour les patients et fiable ce qui
est très important
toujours à nantes c'est ici que le ffs
entre pays de loire alimente localement
mais aussi fourni les autres centres de
distribution des deux régions
des navettes vont de ville en ville pour
maintenir le stock et l'autosuffisance
julien audy et responsable de
l'organisation logistique de transport
en fonction de la catégorie de produits
nous faisons en sorte de transporter les
produits conformément à la
réglementation à la température
différentes dont on a du moins 25 du +4
et du plus haut niveau pour les
différentes catégories trop on est
environ 11 milles transport par an ce
qui représente 1 million 200 mille
kilomètres parcourus tous les ans par
nos différents transports
majoritairement du transport en sous
traitance prenons maintenant la
direction d'angers pour retrouver un
centre est essentielle à la fsc le cube
aider le centre de qualification
biologique des dons souvenez vous au
moment du prélèvement des tubes sont
conservés alors qu'à nantes on prépare
le sang du donneur
ici on l'analyse le docteur sophie le
cam et la directrice de ce laboratoire
tout d'abord il ya une règle à la
réception de ses tubes le matin très tôt
à 5h30 du matin
donc nos employés de laboratoire les
trie les centrifuge et les font partir
vers les différents secteurs analytique
et ensuite on va réaliser des analyses
diverses comme des analyses de sérologie
infectieuses va rechercher les virus
tels que le hiv l'hépatite b l'hépatite
c a également réalisé de l'immuno
hématologie donc c'est à dire des
groupage sanguin et puis on va réaliser
une numération sanguine pour chaque don
ce sont des automates très perfectionnés
qui font ces analyses si besoin en cas
de doute ou revient une méthode manuelle
la marge de sécurité pour le rejet d'un
don est large ce qui élimine les risques
d'erreurs
les services de préparation attend les
résultats de la cub aider pour pouvoir
étiqueté libéré les produits donc soit
tout est conforme en cubes et des tout
est normal et la poche peut partir vers
les hôpitaux soit la poste soit il ya
une anomalie cas qu'elle soit en cubes
et des et auquel cas la poche et écarté
un ça représente moins de 0 5% des
poches qui sont écartés 1
le ffs en région comme sur l'ensemble de
la france possède un maillage
transversale informatique qui permet de
savoir où se trouve à n'importe quel
moment
1 dont les tubes sont étiquetés avec des
codes à barres et un don égal un numéro
de code à barres et derrière ce code il
ya est derrière ce code à barres il y a
d'honneur
[Musique]
prenons la route de tours en direction
de l'hôpital bretonneau c'est ici que se
trouve le f s c'est aussi un centre de
régulation et de distribution l'entité
centre pays de loire est l'une des
meilleures en nombre de donneurs car par
année 48 mille poches sont envoyés vers
d'autres régions et en outre-mer
grâce à un système de régulation de
gérer au jour le jour frédéric cabaret
et le cadre médico technique de la
cellule de régulation des stocks
il consiste à sûrs en une surveillance
quotidienne des stocks de nos stocks de
produits sanguins est d'identifier
d'anticiper les besoins urgents et c'est
ce système régional qui décident chaque
semaine
des donneurs qui seront invités à donner
avec un degré d'urgence plus ou moins
grand en fonction de notre besoin donc
ceci parce que notre couverture de stock
est affinée par groupes sanguins et nous
pouvons être en pénurie dans un groupe
et avoir un stop confortable dans un
autre ce qui explique les campagnes
d'appels aux dons ou les messages
informatiques et téléphoniques reçoivent
les donneurs avant que la poche choix du
livret vers un hôpital une clinique un
centre de soins une analyse approfondie
est obligatoire car chaque produit doit
être mis en parallèle avec le sens du
receveur miles avant la délivrance au
plus proche de la compagnie
le docteur djamel bakkour est le
référent technique en immunothérapie ont
fait les analyses justement pour assurer
la sécurité transfusionnelle de ses
passions la sécurité immunologique on
détermine les groupes sans lien les
phénotypes érythrocytaire et la
recherche d'anticorps anti
érythrocytaire justement pour assurer
pour délivrer des poches de sang les
plus compatibles possible la règle c'est
de ne pas transfusé des globules rouges
qui porte un antigène correspondant à
l'anticorps que le malade a dans ce cas
il faut éviter ce conflit pour éviter
l'accident transfusion il existe aussi
dans les cas compliqués ou de sang rare
une banque nationale à laquelle ils
peuvent faire appel
c'est cette exigence qui a donné à la fs
une réputation est d'être une référence
d'excellence à l'étranger bonjour
c'est pour le dépôt de calvin oui mais
je vous apporte ça tout de suite nous
sommes au magasin en quelque sorte des
produits sanguins
c'est ici que les médecins hospitaliers
ou d'urgence appels pour commander par
ordonnance du sang les avants que la
poche partent vers le receveur
il ya encore une ultime vérification le
bon produit pour le bon patient et
surtout éviter le gaspillage
le docteur béatrice 0 et la responsable
de la délivrance des produits sanguins
nos interlocuteurs ce sont les hôpitaux
les cliniques donc toute personne dans
qui a besoin de sang le prescripteur
c'est un médecin obligatoirement
personne d'autre ne peut prescrire des
produits sanguins qu'un médecin qui nous
donne une ordonnance et sur cette
ordonnance
il ya plein d'éléments obligatoire et
agréablement taire l'identité du patient
le service le nom du prescripteur sa
signature qui est très importante on ne
délivrera pas si on n'a pas la dès la
signature du prescripteur donc le il
nous dira s'il veut des globules rouges
du plasma ou des plaquettes qui sont les
trois parties issues du sang total tout
l'enjeu lui est fait c'est tout l'enjeu
de des donneurs jusqu au receveur c'est
de répondre aux besoins des receveurs à
tout moment donc on a sur le plan
national
tous les fs doivent est à 12 jours de
stock dans tous les groupes sanguins et
après ce sera toute la logistique était
pour trouver ces donneurs pour nous
permettre d'avoir ce stock de deux
choses et voilà vous vous du coup on se
revoit tout à l'heure pour le retour des
caisses oui c'est ça très bien
bon courage envoie bloc opératoire de
gros tony le sang prélevé du donneur
bénévole vient finir son long parcours
dans la veine du receveur d'une scène à
l'autre
c'est ainsi que des milliers de donneurs
bénévoles offrent leur sens qu'il soit
universel comme le haut plus ou très
rares comme le ab moi ce sens et
plaquettes et de plasma qui contribuent
à la vie voire sauver la vie tout
simplement
c'est un produit merveilleuse sans
effort le chouchouter voilà carole
emmanuel julien sophie frédéric djamel
béatrice et tous les autres nous ont
étonnés tout au long de nos rencontres
étonné par leur passion leur humanité
leur engagement le ffs a vu le jour à la
suite de l' affaire du sang contaminé
qui éclate en france au milieu des
années 80 auparavant pour donner son
sang il fallait s'adresser au centre de
transfusion sanguine dont les principes
de précaution était dépassée dans cette
rue parmi la foule certains se croient
sans se connaître et pourtant ils ont
peut-être un lien de sang